are you gonna go to Edinburgh the
comedian Tim Vine he is one the
Edinburgh Fringe festival's funniest
joke award and this is the first time
anyone has been able to do that twice
no wonder he's smiling this morning Tim
what was the joke it was it was this and
I've decided to sell my over Wow
it was just letting Dustin take it up
with the judges Eamonn other trade names
are available we should be able to say
there are hoover sponsoring you for that
i've got i've got another one that i've
got another one that didn't get ya
didn't get two didn't win it but i think
it's a better one in my hacks which as i
say where I'm from there's not enough
crime guess who's been asked to randomly
attack strangers how long I'm really
Jackson hours rubbish how many jokes
would end up in the bin for you Tim
before you actually get to the stage of
the one that you think this is the
business well I have a very very strict
editing process for every ten jokes I
write I'd say I do about ten of them but
how long then would it take you to craft
a joke or to craft an jokes well how
long do you think you've heard that
rubbish I'd be doing it all over and
done with before breakfast and then
gonna do something else I reckon it's a
very serious business and reckon you're
trying to laugh at away there but I mean
I'm reckon that's why your air probably
fell out probably is that it probably is
although I blame it's not you your your
humour slightly more reserved but could
be there might be say what I blame I
blame my mother's father for that not so
much my act
yes okay well what does what does this
accolade mean in terms of work in terms
of profile in terms of career I've no
idea but because I've won it once before
it means that now the books aren't going
to fall off my shelf anymore well here's
here's jack money and there's the Bell I
don't think who've been studying all
that you do here today over to you
ladies I went to I went to all
Tim my son came in with a joke the other
day which I thought was quite funny and
he claimed it was his but I think it's
yours mom I've been awake all night
where the sun's gone and they dawned on
me yours it's not much it's not much
it's not mine but it certainly could be
it's the sort of the level I'm pitch
direction yes and no attempters does
this sort of joke does this type of joke
become a trademark for you as that is
that hi we would know you know is that
how you like to be described well for a
while I've done that sort of thing I've
tried to write something a bit more long
you know longer and you know more
highbrow but it ends up just getting
shorter and shorter and shorter until
you end up with velcro what a ripoff and
it's all the same stuff again there and
work-wise higher things going for you
and where are we going to see you
popping up in the months ahead
well I what you at you and I aim and of
course we did celebrity squares together
do me so I could I fit there coming up
so I mean fun times ahead but I don't
know I just do my thing I try and make
the people laugh or sat in front of me
when you're doing it sir
yeah you're doing a very good job of
that sorry for the the delay on the on
the link there but Isabelle just finally
wants to contribute oh I've got a couple
of crackers for you I want you to give
me your it what do you call a Spaniard
leaving a hospital man well I bought
some camouflage trousers the other day
but I just can't see myself wearing them
I'm so embarrassed
no embarrassed that's part of the thing
is you must front it out okay my career
is based on fronting out tell the joke
and then do that I can't do one more
then enough front I take my car in for a
service the other day but I can get it
through the church doors that's rubbish
grunting tonight at the Edinburgh Fringe
Festival with the joke of 2014 goodbye
thank you very much indeed